suppose i tell you the population of
australia
does anyone know what the population of
australia is
23 it's 23 million 23
million okay good now i'll just write
that out that's 23 and how many zeros is
a million
six zeroes okay
23 million now that number is right
okay tom's on top of his statistics
which is great but here's something
interesting okay what we say the
population of australia is 23 million
we don't mean it's exactly 23 million do
we right
people are uh being born dying all the
time right so this number is like
not exact right it's a it's an
estimation and it's close enough
right yeah would you have to change the
estimation like every couple reviews
um that's a good question i guess
i'm pretty sure they do um like i
remember when i was at school i think it
was something like 20 million
um i don't know how frequently they do
it maybe every couple of years
actually they probably would do it when
they do a census how they don't do
sentences
yeah they don't do it very often because
it's really expensive so
four or five years whatever it is okay
now here's the point right
it's not exactly right but
this is 23 right that's accurate it's
not
closer to 24 or 22 it's closest to 23.
so that's why we call those guys the
significant figures
they are the important numbers in this
number
okay the important digits
okay in the same way when we say the
population of the world is does anyone
know
i think they say it's seven billion at
the moment
seven billion um
again we don't mean there's exactly
seven billion with a zero on the end
um how many significant figures are
there in this ten digit number
there's only one isn't there the seven
again one significant figure two
significant figures
okay now suppose suppose we could right
actually count up let's do let's do the
population australia
okay suppose we went around we walked
around
and we found it was actually this uh i
don't know
five six how many how many numbers do i
need
seven seven eight okay
so suppose we went around we counted
every single one we kept the super huge
tally okay
and this is honey
it's okay 23 million it's all right it's
okay
oh i just didn't see the ones yeah
that's okay it was hiding all right
now in this case if i'm exact it's not
nested anymore
how many significant figures are there
two i i count i can't one two
three four five six seven eight they're
all significant um eight
significant figures okay
now suppose
suppose my numbers are a bit off suppose
you went through
uh who was it i think tom was tom was
really good with his numbers
right so he goes through he checks it
he's like rubbish mr will you kind of
wrong
okay and he gets the real number suppose
this is the real number
you know this is this is mr wu and and
tom gets this
two three one zero oh another zero
zero five zero four okay
he's like look i've checked it out i
checked it out and you guys are all like
yeah yeah yeah we trust
we trust tom's numbers but first of all
he's numbers okay now
remember how we arrived at this we
counted them all up we got an exact
number
not an estimate right how many
significant figures are there
remember we came up with these numbers
exactly the same
way we went and counted it's not an
estimate like this like
i don't know it's something like that it
just happened that
tom got zeros in there right now
therefore
there's still eight significant figures
here
there's still eight they're all just as
important it just so happened that when
when the recount was done you got zeros
okay
but why is this like okay yes now why
are these zeros significant
and these ones aren't
okay there's two ways to think about it
the first way
is oh yeah dude do you want to suggest
some answers
hold on ali had your hand up first say
it again
okay so the first way is see this last
number
not a zero okay so therefore all the
numbers in between even though they're
zero
still significant there's a tom were you
going to say the same thing
yeah okay i'll tell you yeah
okay so that's a very good question
suppose we switched that around i made
it 40. okay
is it seven significant figures now or
is it still eight
now if we go with the suggestion we just
got which is just look at the last
number okay
then you would conclude yep that one's
on the end we've lost it
okay but remember
we we got these numbers by counting
right we went around we counted
exactly right so if they're both exact
it would still be significant if we'd
gone around and this was the number you
ended up with
on the dot no no plus one minus one
right
then all of the numbers might be
significant as it happens they're not
you guys know it's not exact it's just
that you just threw it out there
right so you have to be careful let me
say there's two things again
number one as tom suggested just have a
look and see what's where's the last
non-zero number
if they don't tell you otherwise that's
the last significant figure
so that'd be one two three four five six
seven okay
but if you know information about this
right so it goes to the last non-zero
number
yeah that's right uh nonzero dj if you
know stuff about this like where they
actually got those numbers from
sometimes it's scenic okay